[Music]
this is very surreal it's great isn't it
surreal it's awesome it's really he was
so broke he would like pass out flyers
in front of like the worst comedy clubs
in new york like hey you want to see me
do
five minutes about my iphone
observations and be like get out of my
way
that is true
did you ever bark that's called barking
did you ever bark yeah i barked i barked
for some
sociopaths barking is when you pass out
flyers in front of the comedy clubs yeah
for hours in the snow and get no money
just to tell three minutes of material
well it would be about an hour to minute
ratio it'd be like six hours of barking
to like six minutes yeah it was horrible
yeah it was it sucked but now you gotta
say you're making 200 bucks a year
after taxes is about 35.50
it'll be okay
i'm on adult swim i get paid in like
domino's pizza coop
they know their audience for
a free groupon membership and
can we can we do jamaica we've done it
many times jamaica is a place where
people blame
out of context
jamaica is a place where people play
this is a this is a bit this isn't gonna
work
[Applause]
this is a bit that eric does in his act
that i always do whenever i see him you
know this is now more pete's joke than
my joke basically
so i say is it just me or is uh reggae
the most inappropriate music you could
have picked to open up the show cops
because
you can't put reggae over police
brutality footage it doesn't make any
sense it's like you're under arrest you
old kraken boom jamaica moncomm no no
welcome to the island of jamaica
sunday beaches and blue blue it's
different when i do it
off camera i do it with you off camera
you were killing me yeah yeah yeah sure
i feel here i have to be more
appropriate no no no no no i like you
curtis on this show yeah tvm hey you won
for it we did we get like i think it
says crude humor
that's great
yeah that's awesome crew creamer fudge
it i say
who gives who who gives a h e double
hockey sticks right
doesn't work that doesn't work do you
swear on your show you do right i do i
do yeah does hannibal swear hannibal
swords a lot people say handball you
can't swear on your show hannibal man
can't swear on your show i say yes i can
yes i can hannibal
they try to send to me but i just put in
that language for flavor
he's going to hate that he
hates we do that and we thought he's
doing it we're like i don't know let's
do it for 44 minutes and he's like all
right i just i hate you guys
he does not like that one
[Music]